بحادثه ما بنشوفها كثير بعالم كره القدم
غادر نادي اتحاد جده السعودي ارضيه ملعب
مباراته امام سبهان اصفهان الايراني بعد
ما ابلغوا مراقب المباراه ان المباراه لن
تقام في موعدها وبامكانه مغادره الملعب
فغادر اللاعبون وعادوا الى السعوديه
بالمقابل فريق الايراني عم يقول انه
النادي السعودي تدرب بشكل طبيعي على ارضيه
الملعب ما كان عنده اي مشكله ولم يعترض
على اي شيء بالعكس كان سعيد بطريقه
الاستقبال اللي استقبلوه فيها وبالتالي
النادي الايراني ناوي انه يقدم شكوى
الاتحاد الاسيوي على انسحاب الفريق
السعودي الاتحاد الاسيوي اللي اعلن الغاء
المباراه لم يحدد لها موعدا جديدا واحالي
القضيه للجهات المختصه تداول بعض رواد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي صورا لتماثيل
لقاءد فيلق القدس السابق قاسم سليماني
كانت داخل ارضيه الملعب ودعوا انه هي هي
السبب بانسحاب نادي اتحاد جده من الملعب